pour cette porte de prison qu'elle est
prisonnier sortent de leurs gonds
non c'est quand je regrette un pipi la
démission ça va être à nous tu as they
may la neige brillera ce n'est pas sûr
pas la chasse à le faire du bruit des
soldats qui n'ont rien eu mal au froid
je te regarde et comme il y en avait je
pense pourquoi mais c'est comme ça
toujours avec toi même un vrai un requin
en premier c'est la première fois que
marc ambitionner la salle fou de toi moi
j'ai des enfants je vais laisser un
message au pape et débit des choses à
dire dans ce monde quand même
on peut dire avec des plumes et on
s'entend tralala tu fais caca tisser
sont toujours cinq d'entre elles étaient
parents dans la salle en mars et pas le
nom qui compta c'est la qualité
l'histoire c'est le bouche à oreille
c'est ça qui est important enfin c'est
bush a reçu à voir
écoute pense à l'auteur pense à gustave
petro vie morts dans les geôles
serbo-croate 10 812 on joue pour lui ce
soir
ces journalistes du berry l'ibérique
chance de placer dernière mais c'est une
première
même jean pierre petit et trop vite
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] il est soit enfin
quoi les costumes en quoi les collègues
des basses et des sacs à patates ça fait
prison rôle c'est moi esthétique qui
s'aggrave
comment ça gratte dans les prisons ça
gratte et il faut que ça gratte pour ça
fasse vrai il faut jouer vous faire
passer le message
mais pourquoi tu as mis du rouge à
lèvres on vous fait des prisonniers en
haut mais c'est bien deux c'est mieux
donc bientôt en cinq minutes 10dans
famille et qu'ils attendent la carte de
belgique va peut-être arriver
les belges font message pour une fois
écoute je veux y aller pendant une heure
ce sera fini chamarand bon allez on y va
et merde bastia